Check out this CSS code
from Coca Cola's website.
Looks intense.
Before you'll be able to write CSS
code like this, you first need to
understand the basic building blocks
that make up a single CSS statement.
All CSS begins with what
is known as a rule set.
A rule set is made up of two parts,
a selector, which is the code that
selects the HTML elements that you want
to style, and a declaration block,
which is the code that describes the
styles you want to apply to said HTML.
Declarations are the lines of code
written inside the curly braces.
As an example, let's look at
this simple unstyled web page.
On the left, I have my web page, and
on the right, I have my code for
the web page.
Remember how the head of
the page is used used for
the meta-information about the site?
Style is one of the pieces of
information that goes inside the head.
Anything that goes inside
these style tags is CSS.
For this example, I'll start by
typing p, followed by some braces,
then color: blue, and ending with a ;.
This p is our selector.
It is telling the browser,
I want to select all the p tags, or
paragraph tags, on the page.
The code inside the curly
braces is our declaration.
It reads, color: blue;.
In this line color is the property
we want to change and
blue is the value we want to pass to it.
This is how CSS works for
every property.
You pass it a value, like blue, and the
value describes how the browser should
render the property for the element.
Properties are always
written in plain English.
And they identify a feature of an HTML
element that you want to change.
So let's see what this page
looks like after I add this CSS.
I'll just Save, and let me go refresh
my page and voila, there you go.
When I added the CSS to the web page,
the color of the font and
the paragraph tags changed to blue.